next we love to try new things at this
desk and give them our honest
on-the-spot reviews because this is
drew's reviews
and today
we have a special guest reviewer joining
us right here in the audience it's our
friend florence hi florence hi drew how
are you
so cute
does anyone ever call you flo all the
time do you like it yes
like is that a yes is it like i tolerate
it or i'm connected you know family and
friends will call me flo if you don't
know me please call me florence
that's what i'm looking for honesty all
right rossi what's up first all right
well florence so we're gonna start with
a suggestion from our own drew barrymore
yeah this one caught drew's eye she
brought it here to the desk and mash
reports there's a new cereal in town and
it's made of tiny little pastries and
it's called mini croissant cereal that's
right
this took off on tiff talk by chef
christine wieja and uh
you take store brought croissants you
just take the dough and cut it into
little tiny triangles and then you bake
your own tiny croissants and then cover
it in a mixture of nutella and biscoff
cookie butter and add your milk and
we've got some freshly baked version
here from a bakery in brooklyn called li
apartment 4f and these are made with
their fresh croissant dough dipped in
cinnamon syrup and you guys florence
florence
tell us what you think
they're light
just like croissants
they're not too sweet that's not bad i
don't like sweet cereal and that's not
too sweet
this is good
i would eat this again yeah
i want you around
i am
brother okay what i love about this is
as my good friend florence said there's
no uh not too much sweetness and it's
flaky like a croissant you know those
layers that taste like they're filled
with butter i mean
florence it's time to rate it
what out of five stars do you give it a
four
i love florence
florence you won't give a five for
anything right it's gotta be
extraordinary it's gotta be fantastic
the service it's just gotta be boom you
get a five you know so
[Music]
to translate for florence so four is
really high really high yeah it is i'm
gonna give this a four and a half uh
because i think maybe it could use just
a little more sweetness with it like
some people like the sweeter yeah
cinnamon sugar or something that's good
i'm gonna go over five understood
five
all right so next up this comes from uh
ann hopper hi ann thanks for the
suggestion it's a new cleaning solution
for your home have you ever wish you
could turn your feet into two giant
swiffers and just skate around
collecting dust well now you can with
mop slippers a pack of five
yes look oh they fit on with your shoes
but drew barry had more is modeling them
right now take a look at that
they come in a pack of five
they're reusable they're 15 when you're
done you can just throw them in the wash
florence you want to try them on oh i
like your purple ones thank you
[Applause]
i like your color overload look we could
have a a mopping party invite some
people over to your house put the shoes
on
hey listen come on in put on these new
shoes spray the floor and yeah that's
good
that's a great idea
yeah
[Applause]
i like them you had me at spray the
floors ross ratings um
these are a five out of five for me
these are a lot of fun
i would do this around the house
florence
okay you can have a four and a half here
oh wow
that's huge
that's so that's the highest rating
you've ever given i mean these are easy
if you want to mop your floors listen
invite people over and let them do it
for you
florida genius i was gonna give it a
four but when you said spray first and
then
like move i'm gonna go four and a half
and
[Applause]
i love yeah
[Music]